foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
hello there I'm here at the Dockers Club
in Leith in Scotland to speak to a man
who's writing defined an entire
generation
as trainspotters celebrates its 30th
Anniversary I'll speak to author Irvin
Welsh about its far-reaching Legacy he's
never fought shy of controversy I'll be
getting his views on Nicholas sturgeon
Scottish independence labor JK Rowling
and whether AI might Mark the end of the
creative Industries
so this week choose life choose a job
choose a career choose a family it's
best Rigby interviews with Irvin Welsh
[Music]
Irvin thanks for joining us today it's
really it's a real pleasure to be here
now you have lived in London Miami
Chicago you've enjoyed Global Fame but
we're here in Scotland near Edinburgh
but to be more imprecise because those
are very significant difference we're in
Leath and we're in the Dockers Club what
does this place mean to you uh well
actually I wrote my first book
transporting basically through that wall
uh because my house was above the
Dockers Club at the time when I came
back uh so it's pretty much in my DNA
you know it's like
um my grandfather worked in the docks
and uh it's just there's a whole line of
sort of um Leaf Dockers and the club is
now is going to run by friends basically
who've uh who've kept the kind of spirit
of it alive and uh yeah it's a it's a
fabulous spot in the whole you know the
boxing club across the road Elizabeth
um uh and uh the house that was born in
Prince Regent streets down there and all
that you know but so it's pretty much in
the DNA the the area it's in your DNA
and it's almost like the novels that you
write they feature Leith and Edinburgh
almost as a character in a way
how important is the setting to you for
your your process of writing I think
that even if it's funny because I think
as a writer you're formed by a kind of
childhood in early adulthood experiences
and most of mine were kind of here and
then the north Edinburgh schemes down in
Estuary uh so I think that even if I'm
writing about London or Miami or Chicago
or Amsterdam or whatever it's still
basically kind of formed by my
experiences here you know so it's like
um you know sometimes I'll be writing a
sort of um a big long story and it'll be
set in Amsterdam or Arizona or so
something like that I think Nas is
really Elite isn't it just change it
again you've written many novels your
new one
the view from poachers Hill is coming
out in August
another of course is Trainspotting that
has its 30-year
anniversary
it's a novel that became an era defining
film where you watched I watched it
obsessed with it as a teenager
uh
it had huge literary and cinematic
impact
um when you were writing it did you
think this is going to be this
successful
um I didn't and I can assure you that
the seal Club the view from portraits
Hill uh with myself John King and Alan
Warner the most successful in
Trainspotting because it's a better book
basically but uh yeah written many of
that books since you're always right
kind of better books but you can't
really be responsible for you know the
way it's culturally embraced physically
um I think it's very difficult though
for any book to get that the kind of
attention that transporting got because
uh
we're moving into this
post-cultural basically post-human world
you know where everything is um wherever
we were geared to uh eradicating kind of
but we don't really have a street
culture we have a screen culture now so
everything is um and everything is
geared to sort of um
kind of trying to eradicate another all
forms of pain which kind of uh really
kind of destroys all forms of growth in
a way so we're kind of making ourselves
into robots and if we can't do it in
time we'll invent the AI robots to
replace us so there's not a lot of
opportunity for culture and a kind of um
in a and an online
um Society you know you talk about now
kind of we're moving into a maybe a new
seismic shift in society with artificial
intelligence
there was a writer's strike in the U.S
one of the elements of that being
writers worried about the robots taking
over the creative processes are we
heading to a dystopia
where the robots take over I mean is
that is when you talk about
Trainspotting being about the end of
work we're having a night as well it
seems to be ahead and I mean all these
kind of Silicon Valley nerves have all
got into religion and you know their
thing though is like you know does God
exist not yet but we're going to invent
them you know so that's the the the end
plan isn't it it's to help this um it's
you know it's like the it's like
capitalism neoliberalism technology all
coming together to basically eradicate
human consciousness to to build this
sort of um kind of efficient
self-perpetuating machine you know so I
think the the big battles in future are
not going to be about
um sort of uh sort of you know left
versus right or you know socialism
versus capitalism these things are all
gone and these are kind of products of
the Industrial Revolution
were deindustrialized now and it's all
going to be I think it's going to be
about about humanism versus you know
versus
a form of
um a form of autumn automated kind of
authoritarianism so that that's the
future battle and it's like the um it
seems to me that um human beings have
maybe got quite a bit to make up and
does it frighten you no no it doesn't no
because
um I think that uh
well basically the end game was the same
basically I was like but you know but
what is what we're trying to do is to it
seems like we're trying to use the
technology to create a kind of a sort of
um almost like a puss life moral for
ourselves that we're going to get in
touch with them and die anyway you know
if you look at let's look at all the
people like um McKenna and all the
writings on DMT and all the you know
Moon kind of experiences with DMT it's
like we're heading you know we're moving
towards us you know it's like this this
of human existence is just a Slither
this is like a working holiday we should
be enjoying the working holiday and all
its kind of sort of confusion and
frailties and you know instead of trying
to um instead of trying to replicate
some kind of um utopianistic kind of
sort of post life experience where she's
going to come to us anyway hopefully
you're obviously a very political person
and you do see patterns then in society
from 30 years ago to now
I think no what what's been exposed is
that all the institutions that we have
um
of problem all the time basically you
know they're sort of um
I mean we have um we have kind of this
whole idea that um
we still have everything's geared to
serve to servicing an imperialist
Society you know like um the the public
schools the house of laws the royal
family
um all this kind of stuff but there's
absolutely no relevance to how people
are living the lives now and we're stuck
with those book and they're all survived
with this system which um I mean it's
like the uh the labor party has been
going to abolish the house of laws you
know ever since I've been kind of
sentient basically I remember when I was
about 10 years old it's kind of said I'm
going to abolish those words and done
and now it's like um you know Kirsten
was just saying no that uh well we're
going to flood the house of laws with
more peers first before we abolish it
yeah you think I've heard the song kind
of before yeah uh so um so yeah we have
all these um
all these symbols of kind of of um as
institutions geared towards privilege
and geared towards the protection of
Elites and the father and soft Elites at
the expense of the citizen and um we
worry we wonder why we're in such a
state as we're in you know we can't you
know you have to I think um it's uh we
we need some kind of massive seismic
reform in order to to to create a system
to do you know and everybody's also
thought about designing lives and
designing design a political system that
works for the country so if Alvin Walsh
was PM you'd abolish the lot well
whatever yeah so the bullish the um I
would keep the House of Commons or the
bullish voting
um I would abolish the House of Lords or
the abolish the royal family just all
the things you don't need to the police
Public Schools get rid of them yes of
one school for everybody basically
um and have as much diversity Within
These schools as possible because they
were the one but um I would have
lotteries instead of Elections I would
have like um
650 people would be for a lottery ticket
would become the MPS and that was M40
would become from a lottery of 650 would
become um the uh the cabinet and from
that 40 and one would become prime
minister so when Nicholas Sergeant sort
of said that she sort of all and they
said that they supported
the queen being the head of state and
that's the thing I mean like that's yeah
I mean that's that's what yeah it was It
was kind of um it was it was there was
no real attempt to make these radical
changes that would have that might have
got people interested yeah that was that
was the opportunity to to really kind of
revitalize you know the democracies of
these islands but do you think the fact
that that did not rise up at all was a
reflection of the fact that the islands
and the people
wanted the institution to continue
I don't think they I don't think they
really know I don't think anybody really
knows this is the point that we're all
kind of um we're in a situation we're
all pretty blind and we don't really
have been I don't think um I think it's
worse than you know I don't think people
are partisan for or against these things
I just think they can't be bothered now
you know people people regard
um
politics is entertainment you don't
really see politicians as doing anything
for them or able to change their lives I
mean you look at the same I mean sunak
and uh starmer just seemed to have
exactly the same policies uh and this is
there's no there's no concept of
changing anything for the benefit of
citizens
you voted for Independence in 2014 uh
you've been a long-standing vocal
supporter of Independence are you still
given everything that's happened with
the SNP and I was no other SMP I've
never voted for SNP I've never been a
supporter of this and if you're a member
of the SNP I've always supported
Scottish independence I mean I kind of
support Yorkshire and the burners
Cornish Independence um uh you know it's
like I mean I think that I just believe
that it's time to break up these kind of
Monolithic unitary governments you still
believe that I still believe it more
than ever I think I think everything's
become it's become more manifest than
ever and I don't think you can have a uh
I don't think that um
a new Liberal Party Like The SNP is like
laborers like the conservatives or the
liberal Democrats are
um they're not going to affect that kind
of change because
um I think that uh the great tragedy of
British politics is the the center has
become radicalized not that you know you
always expect the the right and the left
to become rather close but the center
has become radicalized but it's
embracing neoliberalism I think the
senator hostel Embrace social democracy
or even one nation tourism again I think
the center has to sort of um to to
become you know do you think in your
lifetime that there will be Scottish
independence
um I'm not really I think it's
impossible to predict anything I mean I
couldn't you know I couldn't predict for
certain to the union will survive
um I can't protect percentage they'll be
Scottish independence or Welsh
Independence or Cornish Independence
um or London or London is Independence
as a city state or whatever you know you
don't really know what kind of model of
governments is going to sort of happen
but I think that the old imperialist
nation-state isn't serving the citizens
well and I think it has to go basically
but surely surely Scottish but I know
that you
you clearly don't sort of agree with
institutions so you don't necessarily
think that a kind of the way our
political systems work at the moment
affects any change at all
but it seems to me that the only way to
Independence is SMP success at The
Ballot Box that's the route through but
they've had success of The Ballot Box
and it's the The Zone plus
um I mean it's a bit like uh you know
the situation in Spain you know if the
Catalan situation if it's like um
they've they've all they've moved from
the British government are kind of moved
from the small
let's give them what they want if they
want to referendum we'll give them and
then because it was uh because it was
the
um the expectation that uh they wouldn't
lose know their expectation as they will
lose so it's like it's like that kind of
we can't have this happening it's back
to this unitary state and this um
this you know we we're ordained into
this scandination state how did you get
there if
say that you know the the
um anything the the objective has got to
be about the extension of democracy and
the empowerment of people at a local
level and you know I'm kind of agnostic
as to whether that happens uh you know
of the with global or with European or
with British or with Scottish or with
kind of local governmental kind of
things you know I mean I I think that um
it's like the institutions aren't
important I don't care whether this
place is kind of called the Scottish
Republic or whether this place is called
a British Republic or a European
Republic I mean how do you see Scotland
get into Independence if it's not
through the SMP well I think I think in
Westminster and then forcing around you
know like the routes that you could
imagine in the medium time yeah but
that's but I mean do you think there is
you know there is a public protest I
think it has to be a true public process
it has to be through several
Disobedience it has to be through but I
think that these things are going to
work hand in hand with other forms of
public protests and Civil Disobedience
as well you know it's like um uh the
whole kind of um issues you know issues
like the kind of you know the the
incredible kind of growth of inequality
the growth of poverty the the fuel
crisis cost of living crisis climate
change all of these things are going to
coalesce and sort of um and cross
fertilize with each other because uh we
can't you know it's like um
everything seems to be in Decline and as
long as the you know the the kind of
inertia we're trying to impose on on
life isn't going to hold because it's
not you know it's not stability or
tradition that's holding us together
it's inertia and confusion and an
inability to actually Envision a future
but uh hopefully people will start doing
that because uh we're in a very
desperate situation now I think we're
getting to an increasingly desperate
situation where I handle be forced
so you think there could be you you
think in the end Scots will take to the
streets I don't know I don't think it's
too I think I don't think it's taken to
the streets but I think there's certain
things like um if you look at me I just
on Twitter the other day that I just I
was just looking at this this morning it
was like um like Bayern Munich football
funds
um kind of protested against the club's
involvement with Qatar airlines and I
think that you know I think things like
that campaigns like that that affect
Consciousness and what people choose to
do with the money where they choose to
invest and I think you're like kind of
um sort of uh boycotts or those kind of
Institutions and uh and uh companies and
all that that are kind of hostile to
Independence and all that all that kind
of stuff is is I think there's a is a
new Civil Disobedience I don't think
it's like I think taking the streets
with banners and all that people will
always do that I don't think people
equate this is really independence with
the SMP anymore you don't I don't think
so no I mean I think that um the NDC the
I think they see the SNP is um
a kind of um
a sort of a
vaguely Social Democratic
um sort of local government basically
who you know they had who had the um who
did good things with prescription uh
charges and college fees and you know
kept that Social Democratic flame going
so he supported that
um but I think that um this whole kind
of you know the whole social engineering
program that they got into and the the
chance to be I just don't think that's
that was a a thing for for most people
you know I think that um it seemed to be
a strange kind of Hill for a party that
was so ascendant to die on I mean she
would have argued she was trying to
protect minority group groups rights in
a progressive country yeah but you can't
just think yeah but I think it's a thing
that um
you can't um I think the the idea that
you um
you can't build a country you know I
think it showed the limits of um
the idea that you can build a country
with the institutions that you have the
poultry institutions that you've had
which is about eight percent of um the
functions of government
there's nonsense and I think it was
showing these limitations were showing
you know and I think that because of
that people thought well you take you
keep your eye on the ball of
Independence and then we can kind we can
we can have a a healthy debate about
which country which type of country we
want to build you know but uh you can't
impose a view of a country you want to
build on a country that doesn't really
exist as a state yet did you did you did
you feel disappointed about what happens
how did you regret it for her did you
just think what an incredible
implosion I mean what did you think oh
incredible implosion really and uh you
know I sort of um but I also felt that a
lot of that was to do with um
the limits of
um of that kind of model of of
Independence you you
um just on this issue as well of culture
wars I mean you included a
trans character in the Long Knives
storyline it's an area that many
high-profile individuals seek to avoid
because of the toxicity we've talked you
know touched me on this the toxicity
around the debate the way in which it
can really damage people's careers or or
put a Target on their back you chose not
to you you chose to explore that area
yeah I think you have to you have to
look at ever you have to as a writer you
have to take on kind of everything
that's coming you have to be interested
in it and um
to me it's about trying to learn what's
going on you know it's like trying to
it's like trying to um to learn through
fiction through creating characters to
explore all those different themes I
mean the first time I ever had uh rather
sensitivity reader for the for the knob
for the last book The Long nice which
had trans characters and I thought I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna like this at all
unless it's like censorship I'm against
us and um the the the trans sensitivity
was absolutely brilliant you know it was
just I completely didn't
um
okay you know completely had the wrong
end of the stick basically and that they
wanted to make the book as good and as
authentic as possible and they were
incredibly supportive and it did make
did it help to make the building better
to have a trans sensitive why'd you even
have a choice I think well yeah I think
the reason was
um is because it's such a such a an
evolving and new thing you know there's
no there's always written something down
that means you end up being canceled
yeah well not it wasn't so much about
being canceled but but you don't what
you don't want to do is to is to write
something that is kind of hurtful or
wounding to people and is
misrepresenting them you know so you
want to have that there's all sorts of
different trans experiences so you want
to have as many of them in if you like
as possible you know because you it's
not the culture of it all is is so new
that the archetypes haven't been
established yet like they have in other
areas so you have to have an antennae
for that you have to listen to people
and you have to research you have to
keep an open mind about the whole thing
so what do you think about what do you
think about JK Rowling and her
experience in that her concerned about
concerns around women's rights when they
come up against trans rights
um she's been called transphobic for
Rose and those concerns she's been
canceled in places pillory for it what
do you but I mean do you have sympathy
yeah yeah she's not it's like there's um
I think that um
you know as people do agree on You Know
The Enemy for for just about everybody
who's got a violent misogyny because
violent misogynistic characters and it
doesn't matter whether a violent
misogynistic mine is wearing a a suit or
a stone Island
um jacket or a dress you know I mean it
doesn't mean you know there's still a
threat and a menace to women and it
doesn't matter what they call themselves
you know so you have to take that
reality into account you can throw 50 of
the people under the bus but you know to
to advance the rights of um maybe it
kind of kind of zero zero point one but
you have to try to advance the rights of
of any kind of a press minority you know
and um do you think Nicholas sturgeon
forgot that well I think yeah I think I
mean I think that um
I think kind of you know that there's
there's this whole sort of um see Part
of Me Part of Me really is quite
empathetic to the whole idea that um we
we break off all these ossified
definitions about who we are and what we
are you know it's all a product of um
the the Industrial Revolution the
division of labor the patriarchy and all
that kind of stuff so we should be able
to be free individuals and designate
ourselves what we want to be and who we
want to be
um but uh
at the same time you can't kind of um
you can't impose an ideology
uh on the rest of the model just because
you think it's a good idea and again
it's this thing about
um the the lack of contestation of
culture you know culture has to be
contested and debated
um and it's only been debated on you
know it's like if you look at um
the if you look at if you look at the
the the trans kind of you know the the
debate for example if you look if you go
into that it's just
really
kind of seeing how cruel it can be to
each other online and it's like you know
it's it's communist but
um offline most people aren't like that
yeah you know they're they're okay
they're reasonable and they want to sort
of um most women
um uh feel you know in my experience
when I talk to they they see they're
they're very sympathetic they're genuine
trans
people and um most trans people like we
kind of are horrified at the idea of
misogynistic band kind of attacking
women and you know wearing dresses and
attacking women and being kind of
abusive to them online yeah so there has
to be some kind of that you know we're
finding our way through this sort of
Minefield so there must be somewhere
through it and I think we we just have
to kind of um continue to have that kind
of dialogue really do you even worry
though even defending JK Rowling puts
you know it's almost like you can't even
defend Harold's advocate her anymore
it's become so toxic
yeah I mean well I I think it's become
toxic but it's only become toxic at the
margins I mean another joke has given
much of a toss your stores massively
popular and so it was the books like you
know so she's going to be into about it
do you know do you know of you yeah I
mean I've not I don't know that well and
I've kind of I've tried about
um but but just very very generally you
know and uh I mean I think it's you know
I mean I've kind of got tremendous
respect for her first for kind of
sticking to her guns and if like a lot
you know a lot of other women like
Suzanne Moore and um people you know
they've kind of um they've started their
guns but again it's like um
you want to see you know you want to see
people that you know what was on crying
people like Rebecca is a fantastic
character like you know you want to see
people like that who've had that kind of
experience being represented and looked
after and taken care of and not kind of
um it would be people that are just so
far away from the the archetype of the
misogynistic predator in the dress and
all that you know and these These are
archetypes you know and they are extreme
cases but you know there's like um
but the the climate of fear that kind of
thing creates that you know it's like
you kind of in the culture of
narcissistic entitlement particularly
amongst
particularly amongst men who feel that
they've been left behind and feel that
you know they are you know people in
that position are dangerous to women
okay well look thank you so much for
tool to force my pleasure buff
well I hope you enjoyed that fascinating
and far-ranging conversation with Irvin
Welsh if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
Beth Rigby interviews podcast each week
I take a look at the highlights of my
interview and there are some extra bits
and pieces in there too all about
politics of course that'll be on the Sky
News app or wherever you get your
podcasts well that's all from this
week's show from Scotland thanks for
watching
thank you
[Music]